okay this video is about the long essay
section on the ap us history exam now
you might also have heard this called
the free response question or frq i
think it is officially called the long
essay question so that's what we're
going to go with for now now this is the
last essay that you'll be writing on the
ap exam and you get 35 minutes to do it
which is considerably shorter than the
dbq section but the nice part about this
is that you don't have to spend so much
time looking at all of those primary
documents the more challenging part
however is that it's drawing on your own
personal knowledge of the subject matter
so unlike the dbq where you're analyzing
documents and looking at just what's in
front of you here you're really using
your own background understanding of us
history and also bringing up specific
details to help you make an argument so
on this section of the exam you're going
to have the option to choose between two
different essay prompts and you can
choose which of them you want to write
about you only have to write about one
and of course i recommend writing about
the one where you feel most confident
you know maybe it's about a topic that
you like more or maybe it's a topic
about which you feel like you can give
more information but in these cases
always play to your strengths so out of
the two prompts that i was given there
was one about whether the american
revolution was actually revolutionary
and then there was this question about
whether the new deal was actually new or
whether it was more conservative in
nature now i love the new deal so that
is the question that i want to take on
here plus i can remember a lot about the
new deal off the top of my head so
that's going to give me a lot of extra
information to work with so of this 35
minutes that you have on the long essay
question i would recommend that you
spend maybe five to ten minutes of that
and i think 10 minutes would really be
max
to plan your essay
to write a little outline for yourself
to decide what your thesis is going to
be and come up with a game plan that is
going to direct the rest of your writing
time which should be the rest of the
time that you spend
25 to 30 minutes
in this exam period
now again
your mileage may vary on this
you know you might be the sort of person
who can plan really fast and take a lot
of time writing or you might be this
sort of person who
knows that they can write pretty fast so
they can spend some more time planning
but i think this is just kind of a good
overall guideline for how you want to be
spending your time
okay so once you've taken a look at each
of the topics for the essay prompts and
decided which one you want the next step
is to read the prompt itself
really carefully you want to make sure
that there aren't any sort of
hidden strictures in there that might
direct what you are allowed to write
about in the prompt and what you aren't
allowed to write about in the prompt
okay so let's take a look at this
question
some historians have argued that the new
deal
was ultimately conservative in nature
support modify or refute this
interpretation providing specific
evidence to justify your answer
okay so it seems like the heart of this
is about whether the new deal
was
conservative
or
radical
and i think in this context the word
conservative doesn't mean politically
conservative or right-leaning
but rather conservative as in the sense
of keeping something that existed before
so
were the ways of a society conserved
over time or did they change over time
one thing i notice about this question
is that it really doesn't give us much
in the way of a specific time frame to
talk about so it doesn't say talk about
whether the new deal was conservative or
radical in the period between 1920 and
1940 it just asks us to say in the grand
scheme of things do you think the new
deal was ultimately a conservative or
radical movement so that means if we
want to we could actually talk about a
lot of different things really up to the
present and it doesn't even say that we
only have to talk about the united
states i mean this is ap u.s history so
the basis of everything you're writing
has to be about american society but
there's nothing saying you can't compare
american society to other nations in
this time period
okay so our time scope is broad
and even our geography is relatively
broad
all right so how do we decide what we're
going to write about well i think it's
given us three main options here
can support this idea so we could argue
that yes the new deal was conservative
we can refute
and say no the new deal was radical
was not conservative at all
or we can modify which might take the
form of saying
oh maybe it was both conservative and
radical or maybe you even want to say
this is not the right question to ask so
the modify option is kind of like a both
or neither
kind of way of looking at things
now how do we decide which of these
three arguments we want to make i think
one of the most useful things you can do
at this stage
is just make a list
of things you might want to talk about
in this essay so if we're thinking about
the
conservativeness or the radicalness of
the new deal what sorts of things might
we bring up so first let's just refresh
ourselves on what the new deal was about
and the new deal was
this package of programs
which were passed during the great
depression
by franklin delano roosevelt
as a means to try to restart the
american economy and people often talk
about the new deal kind of taking the
three forms of
relief
for people who are suffering for people
who need immediate aid
recovery to try to
get
the
economy back on track and reform
ways to try to change laws change the
way the economy worked so that something
like the great depression didn't happen
again and with the new deal we often
think about this kind of alphabet soup
of agencies you know there's the
ccc the civilian conservation corps
there's the tva the tennessee valley
authority there's the nra the national
recovery administration and the wpa the
works progress administration and these
were all programs that were intended to
get people back to work to try to
modernize the country and to try to
moderate relationships between workers
and corporations
so what are some of the other things we
know about the new deal well the new
deal was a reaction
to the great depression
which was brought on by
some irresponsible banking
in the 1920s a time of what was known as
laissez-faire economics which kind of
said the government was to keep its
hands out of the economy laissez faire
is french for let them do what they will
so let the economy do whatever it wants
well this all right came crashing down
somewhat literally in 1929 with the
stock market crash
and then for
another three years the depression
continued to get worse and worse hoover
had a largely hands-off approach to the
great depression and so he's creamed in
the election of 1932 by franklin delano
roosevelt who promises that he's going
to get things back on track and so
roosevelt had a really experimental
response to the great depression it was
kind of a try something and see if it
works approach so he and his
administration just kind of threw a lot
of different experimental solutions at
the problem
to see what they could do about the
great depression
but the other thing we know about the
new deal is that in the end it didn't
really work now this was partly because
the supreme court
rolled back a lot of the new deal
program saying that they weren't
constitutional which led fdr into his
famous court packing scheme where he
tried to add new justices to the supreme
court basically tilting it in his favor
and he failed at that and the depression
continued to get worse throughout the
end of the 1930s it really wasn't until
world war ii
that
the mobilization for war the american
manufacturing for the war got the united
states out of the great depression
so i think it's clear that the new deal
was this really unique period in the
united states when the government just
tried whatever they could think of in
order to try to improve the economy but
i think the question is if we think
about the basic assumptions of the new
deal itself were those radical or were
they conservative okay let's pause here
to think about that a little bit more
and in the next video we'll decide which
way we want to lean and think about how
to write that essay